بالمائة وسط قلق امريكي هذه
الصفقة. في الحرب الروسية
شركة تويتر وعقب الاتفاق حقق
سامو تويتر مكاسب تقدر بستة
واشنطن من ارسال المزيد من
الاسلحة الى كييف. وقال السفير
كييف تستمر بالاستفزاز. القوات
الروسية تسيطر على قاعدة واصلاح
لتخرج بعدها وزارة الخارجية
الامريكية وتنتقد تصريحات لافروف
قيمتها اربعة واربعين مليار
دولار ايلون ماسك يستحوذ على
الاوكرانية تاهت بوصلة معظم دول
العالم. برأيكم متابعينا من
اوكرانيا بمركبات من طراز جبارد
وتؤكد برلين ان هذا النوع من
للعالم. انتهاكات مؤلمة. هدم
منازل ومحل تجاري لمسلمين شمالي
مسدود بين لندن وموسكو واقرب الى
العداوة بشكل رسمي وهذا واضح
عشرة دولة اوروبية غير للحلف هذا
من دون ذكر اوكرانيا وروسيا. فهل
الناتو وفي مقدمتها فنلندا
والسويد مع العلم ان هنالك ثماني
تزداد قائمة اعضاء الحلف قريبا?
الجيش الاوكراني يطلق صواريخ على
بسبب الحرب الروسية الاوكرانية.
تحرك مشاريع للانضمام الى حلف
عدة اهداف روسية في اكبر صفقة
استحواذ بالبورصة الامريكية بلغت
حال تنفيذها سيؤدي على الفور الى
رد مناسب من جانبنا. الطريق
الى الاستعداد لمعركة طويلة
الامد في اوكرانيا. روسيا تبدأ
المعدات العسكرية للجيش
الاوكراني. بريطانيا تدعو الغرب
بمهاجمة منشآت السكك الحديدية
وخطوط شحن الاسلحة في اوكرانيا
جراء قصف سبعة وثمانين هدفا
عسكريا خلال يوم واحد. حريق في
حقا حسب قوله. الدفاع الروسية
تعلن مقتل خمسمائة جندي اوكراني
مستودع داخل الحدود الروسية.
بوتين سوف نستمر بالمفاوضات لكن
الروسي لدى الولايات المتحدة
الامريكية ان بلاده لن تقبل
ضامنة قبل الموافقة على طلبات
روسيا بنزع السلاح. موسكو تحذر
استولت على منطقة بالكامل جنوب
اوكرانيا. اوكرانيا تبحث عن دول
ضد بوتين هو التضامن والدعم
الدوليين هذا شيء يضايق الروس
باغراق واشنطن كييف بالاسلحة.
اوضح الرئيس الاوكراني الاسبق
روسيا لن تكسب الحرب في اوكرانيا
وسنواصل القتال لكن اوكرانيا لا
اللامسؤولية. اعلنت شركة غاز
بروما الروسية انها اوقفت
هذه عن حرب عالمية. وقالت ان
تصريحات لافروف هي قمة
قيام بسداد ثمن الامدادات
بالروبل الروسي. ورغم ذلك يقول
امدادات الغاز الطبيعي من روسيا
الى بلغاريا وبولندا بسبب عدم
قوله فان روسيا تفعل الكثير
بالفعل لحل الازمة الحالية.
المصورة تجمعا كبيرا من المسلمين
وسكان المنطقة وهم يحاولون منع
المسلمون اقلية مضطهدة في بعض
مناطق الهند وشرق اسيا لكن مجلس
وزير الدفاع البريطاني بانه لن
تكون هناك مشكلة اذا تم استخدام
بضرب مواقع صنع القرار في كييف
في حال استخدمت الاخيرة الاسلحة
هذا التوتر بين تل ابيب وموسكو?
طريق مسدود. بعد تصريحات نائب
وقالت ان غزة اصبحت سجنا في
الهواء الطلق. وان اسرائيل تحاول
فيكتور يوشينكو ان احد اهم
الاسلحة التي يمتلكها الاوكران
ذلك بدأ هجوم روسي غير معتاد على
تل ابيب تغيرت اللهجة بعد اعلان
اسرائيل دعمها لوحدة وسيادة
الاراضي الاوكرانية التي تتعرض
يجب ان تكون جاهزة لاستخدامها في
اي وقت. وهي قادرة على الرد في
انهما مستعدان للحصول على كمية
الغاز الناقصة من مصادر اخرى.
تزال مستعدة للسلام. وزارة
الدفاع الروسية تقول ان قواتها
هذان البلدان العدوان في حلف
شمال الاطلسي والاتحاد الاوروبي
الموقف المبدئي لموسكو ولا ينبغي
التقليل من خطر مثل هذا الصراع.
الامن لا يلتفت اليهم.
والتطورات. المانيا تقرر تزويد
قال وزير الخارجية الروسي سيرجي
لافروف ان عدم قبول حرب نووية هو
الهدم مسبقا. كما اكدوا حصولهم
على تراخيص منذ عشرات السنين.
وتابع الجزائر دولة نافذة في
حركة عدم الانحياز. الروس اصدقاء
لنا بدون شك ونحن اصدقاء امريكا
بدرجة وكيفية اخرى. لا احد يفرض
لمواقف الجزائر غير المنحازة لكن
يجب علينا ان نثبت على مواقفنا.
وتابع لافروف الخطر جسيم حقيقي
ولا يجب الاستهانة به. وبحسب
الدلهي في الهند دون اعطائهم اي
انذار بحجة عدم ترخيصها. المقاطع
الاراضي الروسية موسكو ترد. اكدت
وزارة الدفاع الروسية انها سترد
الاسلحة التي قدمتها بريطانيا
الى اوكرانيا لضرب اهداف داخل
وقتل الالاف من الفلسطينيين.
برزت الردود الروسية بعد قيام
ووجهت له تنديدا شديد اللهجة بعد
ادانة رسمية من وزير خارجية
الجرافات من هدم ممتلكاتهم.
قالوا انهم لم يبلغوا باعمال
المركبات وبالضبط ما تحتاجه
اوكرانيا لتأمين مجالها الجوي.
وقالت الوزارة نريد استفزاز لندن
المباشر بمثل هذه الاجراءات في
البريطانية المقدمة اليها لضرب
اهداف داخل الاراضي الروسية.
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بحملات
متكررة على المسجد الاقصى وتصعيد
الضربات على قطاع غزة. فهل
تستفيد المقاومة الفلسطينية من
لفت انتباه العالم عن احتلالها
غير القانوني للاراضي الفلسطينية
قرارا امميا بتعليق عضوية روسيا
في مجلس حقوق الانسان التابع
لمرتفعات الجولان السورية. وما
العلاقات تعقيدا. وتأييد تل ابيب
لتدخل روسي لترد موسكو سريعا
بعدم اعترافها باحتلال اسرائيل
وجرائم كبيرة بل من رادع لهذه
الانتهاكات. الجزائر تصدم الغرب.
مواقف بسبب عدم انحيازها. وقال
تبون في لقاء اعلامي ان هناك فات
اسرائيل لتدخل روسيا في
اوكرانيا. لم تكتفي موسكو بذلك.
في اطار المساعدات الانسانية.
حرب وشيكة بين روس واسرائيل. لكن
دفاعية بارسال كميات كبيرة من
الخوذ والستر الواقية التي تندرج
حالة الهجوم بحسب وكالة الانباء
المركزية الكورية الرسمية. كيم
بالكامل. بينما تضخ المانيا
اسلحة نوعية لاوكرانيا قد تساعد
سيعيدها الى اتجاهها الصحيح?
الجزائر تنتهج نهج الصين في
علاقاتها مع روسيا متجاهلة
للامم المتحدة. بينما استدعت
موسكو السفير الاسرائيلي لديها
لربما تكون بالوكالة. فهل تستطيع
اسرائيل مجابهة دب روسيا؟ وخلال
يخيف الامريكان والغرب بقرارات
دائما فكيف ستكون ردة فعلهم هذه
علينا مواقفنا. فكيف سيكون الرد
الامريكي والغربي على الجزائر يا
خطابا حماسيا في عرض عسكري اظهر
فيه صواريخ باليستية عابرة
ترى? مفاجأة المجنون. القى زعيم
كوريا الشمالية كيم جونغ اون
تعود الى ستين سنة ماضية. مشيرا
الى ان لا احد يفرض على بلاده اي
للقارات محظورة وقال كيم سنواصل
اتخاذ خطوات لتعزيز وتطوير
اكد الرئيس الجزائري عبدالمجيد
تبون ان علاقات الجزائر مع روسيا
يستحوذ على العصفور الازرق
ومسلمو الهند يتعرضون لظلم
المرة. ما قبل الحرب. اسرائيل
ستزود اوكرانيا بمساعدات انسانية
القدرات النووية لامتنا باسرع
وتيرة. مضيفا ان قواتهم النووية
عن دعم لاوكرانيا وروسيا ترد.
موسكو ترد على استفزاز بريطانيا
عالمية ثالثة. فهل يعد ذلك مؤشرا
على اقتراب هذه الحرب? بوتين
بطريقة استراتيجية ومفاجئة
وسيطرة روسية على مناطق اوكرانية
في حسم المعركة. وزارة الخارجية
الروسية تحذر من اندلاع حرب
عسكري. توتر حاد في العلاقات بين
روسيا واسرائيل. وتل ابيب تعلن
ينفذ وعده بقطع الغاز عن اعدائه
ويبدأ ببعض الدول الاوروبية.
الغرب. ومجنون كوريا الشمالية
يفاجئ العالم بقرار في اكبر عرض